[Music]
what's going on Kevin Hart here now I
understand some of the people for me to
come back to this show it has to be a
big deal I'm tell you I has to be a big
deal last time I did this show became
the most-watched episode ever it was
funny it was great they were good
moments bad moments regardless of what
those moments were people gravitated
towards and people watched so for me to
come back I said we got to go bigger we
got to go better I can't be repetitive
it has to be more so for the first time
ever we are doing the unthinkable we are
doing what people can only talk about
because they were never dared to do
we're about doing little thing called
truth or dab for the first time ever
this has never been done I promote in
the movie you got damn it if I want my
movie to work I'm gonna put myself in
situations like this shoot the dab
either you tell the truth are you dad
there's some hot [ __ ] that's what this
is about
I'm not gonna be afraid to dab in the
hot [ __ ] I cried last time I left with
her I left with a little thing called
the leaky but this particular time
around we're gonna make sure it's better
I'm gonna make sure I'm controlling imma
maintaining that here's the good news I
didn't come by myself oh no I got a cold
start it needs to play with me later
Jeff I got Tiffany Haddish here as well
it's gonna be an amazing show
hey what's going on everyone I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching truth or def a
hot ones special we give our guests two
simple options tell the truth or suffer
the wrath of the last dab and today I'm
joined by two of the funniest superstars
on the planet Kevin Hart and Tiffany
Haddish you can catch them in night
school in theaters everywhere September
28th and Kevin Tiffany welcome to the
show thank you thanks and good and you
see I wore a suit because I'm all
business you look great in that suit and
it's good to see you again I'm surprised
to see you back yeah I know how you are
with hot food but Tiffany I'm curious
with you do you like it spicy like a lot
I love spicy I put spice and everything
on everything if they lit over here she
I'll fire you
[Music]
she ready she ready
so clearly you very much care about this
movie otherwise you wouldn't agree to do
this insane game with us so let's get
the plug out up front why should the
people be excited about night school
very good question if you want to start
well it's a movie about second chances I
can't there you go and it's also got a
lot of heart a lot of comedy and what
else Kevin do it guy laughs there you go
laughs all right well let me break down
the rules for truth or dab for the
people here in the live studio audience
of course you watching it in front of
Kevin and Tiffany there are three
scorching hot chicken wings that have
been doused in various versions of the
last dab I have deeply personal
questions for each of you now you have a
choice when I ask a question you can
either answer it honestly or you can eat
a death way
who's got an answer first Kevin you
because it's your second rodeo so we'll
start with you yeah of course and Kevin
you and the rock you seem to have this
brotherly love thing this good
competitive bromance but it's time for
things to get real okay I want you to
rank Dwayne Johnson acting performances
from best to worst out of Jumanji
Central Intelligence Baywatch
fast and furious and I carried him and
all the movies that we did um you know I
have to say he was really good at
Central Intelligence I'm gonna give that
the best because he played what people
didn't expect him to play uh after that
would be Jumanji the fast and furious
would come after that it's just a bunch
of bad guidelines like you know baby's
gotta take the trash out there was just
a bunch of that [ __ ] seeing at the scene
daddy needs a new gun like just watched
a movie
and they all talked the same so that and
then I would say Baywatch
yeah Baywatch may watch is pretty bad
that would be that would be last for
sure Baywatch
Tiffany ranked these comedians from
funniest to least funny Kevin Hart Amy
Schumer Dave Chappelle Jerry Seinfeld
it's easy
it's so easy Dave Chappelle well Kevin
Hart Jerry Seinfeld Amy Schumer there it
is there it is okay good
let's give me a second why not to be
first why not I just feel like me I
don't know maybe we talked about it
later
I just feel like it's getting hot in
here let's see if it's gonna get a
little bit hotter okay Kevin are you a
card-carrying member of the eat abou T
gang for movies to eat yes like with
this it was my options you can either
answer the question or you can either
wing there's two options it's a fork in
the road here Kevin
I mean I'm outgrown first time in Seoul
day I'm like you know 39 or 40 years
damn man all right you know I'm gonna be
a [ __ ] it is what are they yeah okay
you've been here before I've been here
before huh let me think I've nothing to
do it
eatin ass it's me choosing to take a day
all right
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
all right Kevin this one I pulled from
an actual GED exam so on this question
I'm not trying to pull some embarrassing
anecdote or controversy it's just a
straight up exam question you get it
right you're in the clear you get it
wrong by law you have to eat another
Deathwing okay a school has 18 classes
with 35 students in each class if they
want to reduce class size to 30 how many
new classes do they need to afford the
[ __ ] is going on timeout now let's just
break it down okay you say it's 18 a guy
18 classes right they have 18 classes
let you say it's 35 students in each
class 80 class let's talk about students
in each class and you want to bring it
down to what they want to bring it down
to 30 in each class the 30 in each class
how many new classes do they need to
form what ok well let's first of all
carry 2 to 18
all right don't I can't [ __ ] think
man my mom is hot man so things like one
of them shirt questions where the answer
is like 6 or something uh I'm gonna
think about if is like an 18 okay 35
your news class you want to break it
down there you gotta ask seven classes
they need to add three classes three
classes pump Nick that's why I'm here
right you know we're here to [ __ ]
make a thing of it oh [ __ ]
all right I wanna help you all right
here we go warm up warm up to the hot
spot last time I just went for it and I
think that was too much I need it mm-hmm
mental toughness I saw you in the park
this morning you did what six miles
Zhuge miles so this ain't [ __ ] no ha ha
[Music]
how far I walking a Z oh my god oh my
god oh my god
oh [ __ ] out-of-body experience for
coming out uh oh my god oh my god Oh all
right Tiffany these days we see you're
rubbing elbows with everyone from Oprah
to jay-z - Meryl Streep of all the
celebrities you're excited to meet which
one was the biggest letdown
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I tell you what I told a lot of your
business Frankie ah damn man [ __ ] me oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you alright fine u-kwon not like a [ __ ]
get all right Kevin
Tiffany ain't no waiters [ __ ] Lou we're
approaching ain't no initial line it's
the last set of questions
oh [ __ ] heaven you're friends with a lot
of rappers between Drake Diddy and Meek
Mill who would you trust the least a
house it and why somebody got to go down
on this one I don't know if I can take
away trust it just what say it again
Drake Diddy and Meek Mill
out of those three guys which one would
you trust the least to house it and why
oh [ __ ] meek he been in jail I don't
know man I'm saying meek [ __ ] it I got a
deal with it later if you see it oh my
god Tiffany who is the last famous
person that slid in your DMS trying to
holler oh go on
how's it going trying to holla I just
found out Larry said trying to drive
some try to drop some dick all for news
oh you know you got a [ __ ] answer but
it didn't seem like they was trying to
drive no D so you trying to explaining
if you only gonna save you better eat
their [ __ ] thing
but eat them well yeah try splitting my
deals but the end up put me in his music
video he needs robbing a victim planting
the seeds we see a Drake and let's hear
it for Kevin Hart and Tiffany true sir
dab put it in the history books night
school in theaters everywhere September
28th hold on before we go Tiffany just
you can see like [ __ ] eat that
second winter I'm not bullshitting you
I'll get it did you like hot stuff
whatever eat that goddamn second reading
but tell me if I'm bullshitting Timmy I
say I say eat the wing don't goddamn not
the bone Tiffany now tell me if I'm
[ __ ] sir
sir she's tell me Mommy if I'm
overreacting tell me if I'm a [ __ ] just
let it give it a second to sit it's
spicy but it's not like oh my god what
am I talking to more how to give Tiffany
like I know I'm not playing yo you
telling me that that's not hot
hey jerk your milk down you know look at
your [ __ ] night look at her goddamn
eyes look at her eyes right now they are
watering
your [ __ ] eyes are good yes he is
that's cuz I feel bad about what I said
about Drake I just want a tit yeah since
I hate the second wing can we just edit
the part that I said about Drake cuz oh
I don't want him coming for me I come
for you didn't say not bad okay
you said slitting your deals you said
you ain't get the deed it's nothing bad
but everybody gonna be like oh he didn't
get you the deed what's wrong with you
man does he give it to everybody